[Music]
what's up reject nation of Craig Alba
I'm Johnny realm hi
youtuber influencer yeah are we doing
frat boy things yeah I guess so
because you are in college howdy hey
what's the frat boy son leg sir I
suspect foul play
we are going to watch today from a
channel called the bigger ten actors who
turned down huge Marvel roles and why
they refused is it not the Binger what
did I say the bigger are you sent a
finger I think I said big you're right
yeah that's why you're the one in
college
yeah Johnny go follow him on whatever is
listed in the description box or else
you won't return if you don't want him
to return
follow him anyway what oh yeah I get
followers undo it yeah you do okay cool
life is about helped me build my ego
followers that's right
okay that's great followers and if
you're not getting more followers you
should be depressed that's a good piece
of advice for all it is I actually don't
know who turned him anymore for growth I
only know like - I know like walking for
I know what Ray's yeah but let's watch
this become so established
at all
take a look wanted to do being a real
item by George whoa hey have hair like
in time like betty was just sending you
do
the music wait yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we don't scientists Disney of Justice
having an acronym for UCC battle give me
that he turned the branch son Blake you
did barely detail and frankly you know
me him to only anthony hopkins you have
ever been considered a part because
let's face there are few women actors
more legendary than him
yeah I love this this value isn't all
about the cash rumor has it that the 40
year old didn't feel that he had it in
him to jump through all the hoops the
CGI blockbuster needed
Jared Leto was also considered for the
role which eventually went to Benedict
Cumberbatch dude no way let's see what
it turns out the big I think that's the
Ohio Man 3 I think so I think it right
we are DC chills Chastain is going from
hit to hit yeah
oh yeah time to Strauss that's why you
don't make contracts that's why when you
what
it's a decent trade-off memory EE Scott
is watering
it's hard to believe putting together
x-men for the first time cool at first I
wasn't even alive I was born when he
came out before it was stopped still
stuck on that we're talking about
something Doherty forthat story really
whoa why not no that would have been a
sinister I like image something a little
bit more sense he's got some of the best
se godly LOM that's very he was so scary
and
[Music]
[Music]
yeah one day at a time also got cancer
[Music]
we'll see how do you think when he was
in the audition room casting directors
were like let's not talk about the
elephant in the room
hey guys I've taken over the real
rejects it's gonna be Johnny and John
that's what happens into people who do
improv er tryna be definitely most of
these I haven't heard of Olivia Munn for
Vanessa and talked about petanque or Tom
Cruise I'm well as much as I love Tom
Cruise I'm gliding in higher man because
yet I feel like he would really try to
control it too much mmm just knowing
everything I think he's brilliant I
think having him just with his mission
impossible franchise is special but a
lot of times he steps in and it's like
yeah it makes every producer listen he
takes cruise control Timothy Olyphant as
Ironman that would have been interesting
I think
Timothy all the font is one of the most
underrated gems that we have he's a
brilliant comedic actor he's a wonderful
dramatic actor too in terms of like
celebrity interviews he's just one of my
favorites so yeah yes so awkward and so
weird and so chill I love Timothy
Olyphant whole personality do you be
very different than Robert Downey jr.
but I could see him putting his own spin
on it in it actually working yeah
definitely I think Downey jr. does
ultimately work best obviously but I
think Timothy Olyphant could have
brought something that's very
interesting
he liked the humor and Iron Man I think
he really could have brought and like
the weird narcissism to another thing
that I'm curious about is how Iron Man
was supposed to be before Robert Downey
jr. came in it's the same thing we're
doing with Jessica and Levitt and Peter
quill I'm curious how Peter quill was
supposed to be as a character when
they're approaching Joseph gordon-levitt
because now Peter quill is known for the
mannerisms that Chris Pratt brought to
it so I wonder if it's the same thing
with like Iron Man you know is what Iron
Men have been as snarky and witty if it
weren't for Robert Downey jr. and stuff
I think Joseph gordon-levitt can totally
bring that I think he's like really
evolved into a cool dude yes Arthur
always wants more credit but there's a
self-deprecating level - yeah that's the
part that I don't really see so yeah cuz
I feel like Joseph of love is definitely
really funny and he's really cool I
could see him doing that a lot of like
I'm star Lord come on man star like I
can see just to go to love it doing that
yeah
but then there's other elements first
fat really made it his own and James
gonna less people improvise and James
gonna knows how to write nor does the
actress he has so I feel like it just
would have been different
what's that line that he has endgame
when he's talking to Thor he's like
why'd kill my my dad there's a planet
you know my dad caught my mom and it was
like oh I had to call for people who
know me I even have a keychain doesn't
flush your photo up here that has Mel
Gibson on it my actual sex
now give some a big fan of hit hit miss
Odin things huh haven't seen anything of
his not even the the taped to his ex I
think it's best Anthony Hopkins just
fits Odin which is so traditional
Anthony Hopkins is granddaddy and we
love that
Odin's granddaddy you know I'm not sure
what a Mel Gibson take on Odin would
have been I probably could have done an
accent sure you know guess it had an
Australian accent a quick it faded as
he's been in the States but him is Oda I
just don't see how that would have
worked do they say why he turned it down
they said no because of the
controversies yeah they said he's just a
PR nightmare yeah oh yeah I know that
would have been terrible there's a lot
of dead space Alexander Skarsgard is
Thor I could see him doing the Thor
from the first couple Thor movies in the
first Avengers movie and age of Ultron
obviously but for what Thor has evolved
into with Ragnarok an endgame that is a
Chris Hemsworth special touch like only
Chris Hemsworth could do that and
clearly they tended to what Chris
Hemsworth could do by that point I was
Anderson I'm sure
comedy and whenever he's funny and
Trueblood but he's just brings a very
different layer but I love him in True
Blood and I think he's great in the
first season of that show with all the
women girls no no wait that's a big
little wise oh yeah yeah they shot that
sorry my hometown is Salinas and the
Monterey is like right next to Salinas I
was in town when they're shooting that
they all shot bumblebee by my hometown
two while I was there but I was on I had
high school do you think we're on some
like podcasts where we can just riffle
the topic about things is that not what
this is don't all men in their third
start a podcast
sorry I've worked at Collider for too
long Emily Blunt has got to get into the
MCU at some point I mean the big rumor
has been like oh when they do fantastic
for you get John Stehr sinski and Emily
blunted there and Tim's story will
direct again yeah lover Chris Evans
returns or even door sorry captain Mary
go put him back for your toys he's great
as Human Torch
like you hear black way like yeah she
would have been great
mm-hmm Peggy Carter yeah she would have
been great I love the pics that we
ultimately settled on but Emily Blunt
especially with her working edge of
tomorrow and a quiet place like that
level of John right yeah an action in an
edge of tomorrow
Hubie those two movies are incredible
Emily votes to me easily one of the best
actors overall yes working today she is
absolute you can do anything
it's sober she's Mary Poppins dude good
thing Jessica Chastain didn't agree to
that Maya role machine instead
Gulliver's Travels
no that was only Blunt Jessica Chastain
was working on I don't know it doesn't
matter oh yes that scheduling convoy
fans yeah there'll be other roles now
we're going into the vault of Marvel now
all these actors could have a second
chance yeah they'll open up the
multiverse and then Tom Cruise is Iron
Man all of a sudden they should do a
multiverse of the multiverse of madness
and they should have a different range
and have joaquin phoenix be you I don't
think walking in Phoenix would have fit
in at all with Doctor Strange now I
think he would have been a good doctor
strange
I don't think you
would fit in with the MCU and the marvel
in the way they like to film anyway he
would have possibly been important even
a little bit surprised at Christian
Bale's it could possibly agreeing and
being said I don't know about that may
not work out well
oh it's Jared Leto who's the other Joker
that's why they made a joke yeah yeah
nah I think Benedict Cumberbatch yeah I
honestly was like skeptic about that too
cuz I felt like he was gonna take a
similar stance with Joaquin Phoenix and
be like I don't know man like this is my
thing because Sherlock he's so good in
Sherlock yes incredible in that and he's
incredible and most things Doctor
Strange is like the last movie I saw I
watched it like after Captain Marvel I
finally said Doctor Strange because I'm
vide he was so good in in vani war yeah
that's a dude what this is a fascinating
listing the multiverse of madness they
should do just a whole bunch of whatever
they're doing on Christ on Infinite
Earths all these different people that's
right they should do that here with all
these actors that'd be great
guys guys guys reject nation make sure
to throw a subscribe button over to the
being ler as soon as you can
Johnny follow him on YouTube and social
media handsome kid 12 years old you
could subscribe and click our
notification bell who do I shout out
here Robert Downey jr. Philip J Smith
jr. that I got I'll attendance with the
page for the day shout out to man named
Philip J Smith jr. Johnny picked him
because check this out our DJ cookie Jay
Robert Downey jr. Philip J Smith jr. oh
my god when they do my multiverse movie
that I'm hoping for you will be the
alternate Iron Man when they go into
earth 58 or whatever in that movie
that's your future Philip J Smith jr.
you're the other Robert Downey jr. and
also he's related to Harry Connick jr.
and Philip J Smith jr. was also
considered for the lead to take over
Arnold Schwarzenegger role in the movie
Junior
that's all the juniors a guy my initials
are junior everything has to be about
you your eyes you're right